[Music]
so
this is how it went down
[Music]
we filmed the call out video for the
stay home film challenge in quarantine
in london
and you guys commented a lot
yeah
well ask and you shall receive
ladies and gentlemen i present to you
the 60-second video master the one the
only
nulls
daily
hi my name is nas from nas daily and i
make videos today i will be judging the
best five videos from the stay home film
challenge by great big story
let's begin
submissions have come from far and wide
and boy did you guys get creative
we saw horror movies
action funny comedies animation there
were even some insane stop-motion films
we couldn't be prouder
and what better judge to have than nuzz
daily
nars thank you so much for joining us
and agreeing to be a judge for our stay
home film challenge how are you i'm good
i'm just stuck in my house and still
making videos and i'm happy to be
participating in your challenge so for
anyone who doesn't uh know you
can just give us a bit of background on
yourself my name is nosire
nickname is nas
i make one minute videos
the way i say it is great big story and
ass daily are like twins that were
separated at birth so my videos are
about people and places around the world
that are interesting
so of the hundreds of fantastic entries
we received
nasa's gonna pick his top five so nas
you ready
let's do it number five
hello i'm lorita jackson
like i've loved plants for a long long
time long before it was popular
i think i got it from my mother and
other family members a lot of times i
find plants that have been neglected so
i call myself a foster plant mother i
know the type of plants that work well
in my home and i look for plants that
don't need a lot of bright sunlight i
would say start with plants that are
easy to take care of there are many many
types of plants that don't require a lot
of sunshine don't require a lot of
watering and are pretty foolproof and
then branch out
and just try your hand at different
plants and uh just take care of them
show them some tlc and you will be very
happy with the results
cute look i'm a big fan of videos that
have a story i really like don't care
about how good you are as a filmmaker i
don't care about your camera your sony
your canon your drone i don't care i
care about are the words you're telling
me interesting did you put enough effort
into those words and for me that's what
makes a good video yeah
i could really see this being on great
big story like the way it was structured
the music
and it featured plants so that's a
win-win as well
that was number five on to number four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very cool this is nine seconds but i
think a lot of people don't appreciate
that this probably took nine hours to
make you know this is very hard to make
so really
good job on the effort
i mean we have nothing else to do right
so good job on the effort that this
person has put in making this video
especially trying to keep a child
entertained for that long i mean like
you said nine hours it must have and we
also have um some behind the scenes as
well so there's a kind of quick video to
show
you know the time lapse of how he did it
nice you ready for number three let's do
it
the place you call home contains a whole
universe invisible to the naked eye
the average american household has
around 7 000 distinct species of
bacteria and fungi
many people assume that these little
critters mostly hang out by your toilet
seat or maybe your trash can but if you
are looking for the biggest crowd of
microbes you'll actually find them in
your kitchen sponge but this microscopic
ecosystem is always changing
for example having a pet in your house
transforms its microbiome completely
although microbes can't really move by
themselves they end up all around your
house in some places you'd never expect
but you'll be okay probably right now
your home microbiome is the safest place
you can be especially compared to some
of the other microbes that you can come
across when out in public
nice
cool
this is relevant like everybody cares
about this stuff now and it's so cool
that this content is happening now and i
really enjoy the animation in this one i
mean the way he actually masked out
objects the animation would appear from
behind also tracking it to the footage
takes a bit of time there so they really
come off nicely
so how did you become the king of 60
seconds
well i think that is a very
generous term my attention span is very
short and i realized someone should make
videos that i would watch and so i said
i'll just do it myself my first 300
videos were terrible but i did them
every single day no matter what and
after trying 500 600 videos in 600 days
i became really good at telling a story
in very short time
what sort of inspires you as a filmmaker
what inspires me is is you know look i
don't i don't know what an aperture is
to this day i don't know what a shutter
speed is i don't know anything and i
want to remain that way and the reason i
say this is because
a filmmaker
this job is not
to make films it's to tell a story my
first 150 videos i didn't have a
microphone
i didn't know i needed a microphone and
i think it's okay
as long as the story is is
does resonate with people how about you
austin what's your favorite part
i think my favorite part of filmmaking
is being able to tell someone's story
and doing it justice but at the same
time being creative trying to make that
video stand out from others
okay i think we're ready for number two
let's do
[Music]
there's one thing you it you gotta do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay first of all i want to be this
guy's friend
that's a fact right this guy looks so
much fun i want to be his friend
second of all
i don't know how to make this video
i really don't know it's it's incredibly
hard to make because i don't know how to
do with these animations so i appreciate
it whenever i see it it's very cool it's
very relevant
it's a song
i wish there was a little bit more
lyrics but wash your hands at least
that's what's gonna stick in my mind
agreed and also the jacket love that
jacket
zach please
she wanna let me borrow the jacket and
the color scheme of the animation is the
same as a jacket and so it looks like
it's part of the video very cool
okay we made it number one now this is
your top pick there's a reason this is
number one this is my favorite okay
right let's go
hi i'm just karen singh and i make
environmental documentaries in punjab
from last 24 days i'm practicing
self-isolation by staying home and
it's hard
especially for a guy like me whose job
is to visit forest and film different
stories
i thought i couldn't get any of those
stories without accessing the field
until i found one at my home due to
lockdown the pollution levels have gone
down and i started witnessing drastic
improvements in the visibility so i
started documenting this temporary
mitigation air pollution from my rooftop
eventually other filmmakers joined this
movement
some captured the newly arrived birds in
their backyards some photographed the
mountain ranges that were not visible
earlier i got a glimpse of milky way
despite living in a floated city the
footage we are collecting will be used
for future environmental projects and
due to this lockdown we are able to work
together on something which is bigger
than us and that makes me happy don't
let the lockdown restrict yourself find
creative ways to deal with it and you'll
be good
first of all if you don't hire this guy
i may okay that's one i don't because he
has a great big story poster in his back
in his wall so you should hire we saw it
we saw it number two this really is one
of my favorite videos i mean look it's
it's the words i don't i don't give a
damn about the visuals the visuals were
good but the words it's like he took
something bad and he made it good in 60
seconds that power
to change good bag to good in 60 seconds
is priceless yeah it was it was a really
great job and even some star time lapses
all from his rooftop i mean absolutely
fantastic job congratulations
thank you so much i really really
appreciate it it's been fantastic having
you on any final thoughts
this is the time to build right this is
the time to make videos right now media
is more important than ever in the
history of the planet it was if you're
not making media right now you should be
starting yesterday yeah and i agree
i just want to thank now so much for
being a judge on our challenge it's
inspiring to see what you guys have
created especially being quarantined so
congratulations i know this was a 10
minute over 10 minutes but uh do you
want to sign us off
of course
all i gotta say is one line
that's one minute
see you tomorrow
[Music]